okay Leute wenn jetzt gleich das Licht
angeht bitte nicht lachen ja was
[Musik]
geht hey Leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen Video und
zwar ist ja bald Halloween und ich habe
mir gedacht komm machst du doch auch mal
so ein passend zum Thema einen Video und
zwar habe ich mich auch dementsprechend
so ein bisschen gestylt bzw ich habe es
versucht auf jeden Fall gibt's heute von
mir die krassesten Kostüme ich habe ein
bisschen im Internet recherchiert dann
gibt's auch noch ein Gastauftritt und
dann erzähle ich euch auch noch wie ich
das hier so hinbekommen habe bzw wie
schon eben gesagt versucht hinbekommen
ich wünsche euch ganz viel Spaß wenn es
euch gefällt gibt ein Daumen nach oben
und ja so das erste Kostüm das mir
eigentlich ziemlich gut gefällt ist auch
relativ einfach und zwar ist das einfach
diese Maske soll so ein The Walking Dead
Zombie nachstellen oder so ihr müsst
euch die einfach ab den Wangen hier
draufkleben bisschen Schminke darüber
oder so dann passt das schon also
bisschen Blut keine Ahnung und dann wird
halt so ein zersplitterter Kiefer
gezeigt der so runterhängt ich finde das
eigentlich ganz cool gemacht und
deswegen habe ich die mit ins Video
genommen es gibt aber auf jeden Fall
noch B Kostüme wie z.B mein Favoriten
und zwar handelt es sich hierbei um so
ein Metzger oder Schlachter der war
gerade halt ein schweinschlachten und
hat generell seine Sachen halt ziemlich
Blut überströmt sind auch nicht mehr so
die neuesten auf jeden Fall was ich auch
daran richtig cool finde ist dieses Teil
was in der Hand hält das sieht auch so
ein bisschen gruselig aus und ja der hat
sich halt gedacht komm oder die
Geschichte dahinter soll halt sein der
hat sich ein Schwein genommen hat das
geschlachtet und den Kopf dann halt
Gehirn Augen raus und hat sich das dann
einfach über den Kopf gezogen ich finde
es richtig gut gemacht und gefällt mir
echt sehr deswegen kann ich euch das nur
fen falls ihr noch ein Kostüm sucht ja
dann kommen wir jetzt auch schon zum
dritten Kostüm und zwar habe ich jetzt
einen kleinen Gastauftritt für euch und
zwar der Liebe Tim vom Kanal Tim tes ich
hab auf Instagram gesehen der hat
irgendwie so ein cooles Kostüm kreiert
das wird euch jetzt gleich ein bisschen
vorstellen wie er das halt so gemacht
hat ich wünsche euch viel Spaß und ja ja
Leute bevor jetzt aber Tim dran kommt
ihr werdet bestimmt sehen der hat so ein
ähnliches T-Shirt an wie ich also auch
so ein rotes halt mit Blut voll
getröpfelt auf jeden Fall wollte ich
euch deswegen kurz vorweg mal zeigen wie
man das macht das ist eigentlich ganz
einfach ihr könnt euch vielleicht auch
ein bisschen Denken auf jeden Fall nehmt
euch einfach irgendein T-Shirt da kann
ruhig was drauf sein man sieht es im
Endeffekt nachher eh nicht ich habe mir
einfach ein T-Shirt genommen damit so
ein bisschen Halloween stylisch aussieht
macht das am besten zu zweit zieht hier
die Ärmel so ein bisschen lang und
schneidet die einfach ab dann sieht das
so ein bisschen Zombie mäßig aus halt
auf beiden Seiten und den Kragen hier
oben könnt ihr auch noch einfach ganz
abschneiden dann hat das hier auch mal
so ein Effekt und hier
so auf den Oberkörper wo das T-Shirt
dann halt sitzt hier auch noch ein Loch
rein hier auch keine Ahnung auch mehrere
Löcher reinmachen und dann haben wir
einfach ich hole die mal eben aus dem
Mülleimer ich habe die schon weggeworfen
und zwar habe ich dann noch diese beiden
Kunstblut Tuben aus demem
Spielwarenladen geholt ich glaube das
müsste es zur Halloween Zeit eigentlich
überall geben und dann habe ich mir halt
einfach das T-Shirt genommen habe das da
so drauf getröpfelt und dann immer mit
dem Kragen den ich abgeschnitten habe so
ein bisschen verrieben und scheiße das
tropft voll und ja das Endresultat ist
dann halt dies ich finde es sieht ganz
cool aus ihr müsst aufpassen weil das
färbt ziemlich stark durch ja als erstes
hat sich Tim einfach einfach so ein
weißen maskupstick genommen den Link
dazu ist natürlich auch unten in der
Videobeschreibung dann hat er einfach so
ein bisschen auf seinem Gesicht
herumgemalt das ganze verwischt das halt
so eine weiße Oberfläche entsteht und
als nächstes hat er dann einfach den
schwarzen davon genommen und auch so ein
bisschen die Augenlider und Augenränder
angemalt und natürlich auch verwischt
damit halt so ein bisschen Halloween
Effekt entssteht ihr wisst schon was ich
dann persönlich ziemlich cool finde ist
diese Linse die er sich halt besorgt hat
und einfach ins Auge gesteckt hat finde
ich sieht richtig cool aus und Link dazu
ist natürlich auch wie immer in der
Videobeschreibung um das ganze noch ein
bisschen gruseliger zu gestalten hat er
sich einfach noch mal das Kunstblut
genommen und so ein bisschen über das
Kinn und den Hals geschüttet was auch
mega geil aussieht finde ich und ja ihr
könnt dazu auch einfach Ketchup nehmen
habe ich auch ausprobiert das sieht dann
ungefähr gleich aus nicht ganz so echt
aber auf jeden Fall auch cool und damit
jetzt auch gleich schon wieder zurück zu
mir und zwar bevor ich euch jetzt mein
in Anführungszeichen cooles Kostüm
vorstelle wie ich das halt gemacht hab
gibt's erstmal noch einen weiteren Tipp
und zwar seht ihr hier noch eine weitere
Maske die trägt den Namen mutationsmaske
ich denke mal weil Hal zwei Gesichter
sind die gefällt mir auch echt sehr gut
ich finde die Gesichter halt gut
gelungen das einzige was ich daran nicht
verstehe ist wenn ihr so von der Tür
steht ihr müsst euch ja dann so
hinstellen damit der von dem ihr Süßes
oder Saures heiß glaube ich wollt
halt euch so wahrnimmt was halt das
Kostüm zeigen soll ja und dann kommen
wir zum Schluss zu meinem tollen Kostüm
hier ich weiß jetzt zwar nicht ob es
ganz so toll ist aber so schlecht
sieht's jetzt auch nicht aus so wollen
wir mal ehrlich sein auf jeden Fall habe
ich das eigentlich relativ schnell
hinbekommen ich habe glaube ich eine
halbe Stunde oder so gebraucht ja ich
habe euch ja eben schon erklärt wie dies
T-Shirt zustande gekommen ist und jetzt
habe ich mir noch so ich habe mir dann
aber auch ebenfalls gedacht ja irgendwas
musste so im Gesicht auch noch machen
und da habe ich mir einfach ein Verband
genommen ich habe das jetzt gerade schon
so ein bisschen improvisiert hier nach
10 Minuten ist mir dann auch geglückt
den Verband durchzutrennen dann reißt
den einfach ab oder schneidet den durch
keine Ahnung das
[Applaus]
geht und zwar nehmt ihr einfach so ein
Verband ich weiß nicht wie lang der ist
so 80 cm
dann knotet ihr euch den einfach zweimal
um Kopf rum und bindet den hinten wieder
zusammen und dann seht ihr erstmal aus
wie so ein Judo Kämpfer oder so ich weiß
nicht so dann könnt ihr den natürlich
noch so ein bisschen richten dass das
passt und dann habe ich hier ganz
einfach so hier Schmink Schminkstifte
genommen und habe mir dann einfach hier
ein bisschen rot drauf gemalt so
generell über ein ganzen Kopf und dann
ist halt das entstanden was ihr jetzt
wieder seht und meine Freundin hat mich
dann noch ein bisschen unterstützt indem
sie mich hier so eine Augenklappe gemalt
hat glaube ich kein Ahnung sollte halt
so ein bisschen der Zombie Effekt sein
also wenn ihr jetzt nicht unbedingt viel
Geld dafür ausgeben wollt dann ist auf
jeden Fall sonkostüm hier richtig gut
geht schnell und sieht auch gar nicht
mal so schlecht aus ich hoffe jetzt ihr
könnt ja mal in die Kommentare schreiben
wie ihr das findet sieht's gut aus sieht
scheiße aus seid bitte ehrlich so und
dann befinden wir uns jetzt auch schon
in der endcart und zwar habe ich noch
zwei weitere videotipps für euch die
haben ebenfalls so ein Halloween Video
gemacht wie ich bzw ein anderes Thema
natürlich auf jeden Fall seht ihr hier
einmal auf der einen Seite das Video von
Jako wusch und auf der anderen Seite das
Video von den lochis checkt auf jeden
Fall bei mal ab ansonsten war's das von
mir ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen und
wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten Mal
wieder haut rein Leute ciao